what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch today Deadpool three plot revealed
Ryan Reynolds pitch to Marvel here it
could possibly be along the lines with
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe do
you think he'll kill the superhero team
giant panda king what were you saying
that cuz they're today's video sponsor
yeah child I don't think they'll be cool
with us saying that we should kill the
sponsor then let's transition if you've
been following this channel over the
last couple of months you might have
heard us call out gpk before ongoing
sponsorships are so cool Greg tell them
about giant panda King tell them about
giant panda king I'm trying to gpk takes
fandom and creativity to a whole other
level
internationally gpk is best known for
the Empire strips back their burlesque
cabaret show set in the Star Wars
universe
they sent us over there Wookiee rodica
magazines which reread cover to cover
pink a seventies Playboy mags set in the
Star Wars universe truly lived in truly
creative I caught greg touching himself
to them then I joined in but the main
thing that I loved that they sent over
to us was their Gotham 1919 to 1939 book
I read this whole thing in two days and
after John found out that I read it he
felt pressure - Rita - and he loved it
as well oh I'm a people pleaser and a
procrastinator it takes the characters
and mythology of Batman and reimagined
them as part of depression-era American
history from the war to end all wars to
the crash of the stock market from
enforcement to Prohibition to the rise
of celebrity gangster I would love to
see this book adapted into a movie but
documentary like style talking about
Deadpool while promoting a book set in
the DC Universe was a great call Gregg
head on over to their website today and
Thank You gpk for sponsoring this video
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything or leading to
these I really hope it is three news or
news about the plot of Deadpool 3 what
Ryan Reynolds has pitched Disney for the
next film in what could only be
described as genius it's the perfect
plot that would not only be extremely
satisfying to see but would actually
make the most sense to do based on all
the new characters coming to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe from Fox this plot
would help clear everything up and make
it to where there's not really that much
confusion in the new Marvel Cinematic
Universe which means that Deadpool 3
would be a movie not only involving the
old Fox characters including the x-men
but would also involve current MCU
characters and new MCU characters that
are upcoming as well so let's dive into
Ryan Reynolds's awesome idea for the
news first if you new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a Wolverine a Funko pop to
enter all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below
so today's leak comes from a Marvel
insider who has been right about many
many things in the past especially when
it came to Avengers and game everything
that he leaped ended up becoming and
many of you know who he is we've talked
about him several times on this channel
and my best friend a lover doh what
exactly Deadpool 3 could be about he
said Deadpool kills Fox's Marvel
Universe was one of the ideas did a
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe book
this book was not can into any of the
comics or any of the story but it did
happen and basically Deadpool goes on a
huge killing so I came in even though I
watch your cos it's kinda more of a
horror story than anything else that's
not exactly
Ryan Reynolds has pitch to for the next
step course though instead what Ryan
Reynolds has simply offered is a chance
to clean up the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and a hilarious way that they
could do it with tableau by now the
Disney file still resulted in all of
Marvel's characters coming back to I was
like it's gonna be Deadpool they could
do the Fantastic Four in characters like
Galactus and Doctor Doom etc which means
that none of the x-men films including
Dark Phoenix Xmen apocalypse and all the
other ones that people don't like too
much never happened in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the stories that
happened in the Fox universe basically
didn't happen however that could be
quite confusing as new characters such
as Professor X magneto Cyclops Beast all
of them start to enter the Marvel
Cinematic Universe unless it's made
clear by somebody that these old
characters are now basically dead they
don't exist all of the old Fox x-men
characters are gone we aren't going to
see them in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and what better way to clear
this up and kill off all of these
characters than to have Deadpool do it a
character who can break the fourth wall
really is now I made it to the MC but
these guys didn't so I got a killing
just to make sure there's no confusion
about who made it over and who didn't
and this doesn't even have to be an
entire plot point to the movie but
nonetheless would be hilarious and it
would also offer the clarity to some
people who might be a little bit
confused about exactly who's boss has
met with Marvel Studios at least a few
times already to talk about Deadpool and
on the live with Kelly and Ryan show he
even admitted that they're over at
Marvel Studios now he said we're working
on it right now with the whole team
we're over at Marvel now which is the
big leagues all of a sudden it's kind of
crazy so Ryan Reynolds has already
mentioned that they are working on
Deadpool 3 already now another part of
this tweet by Roger Ward was that
Michael Bay may direct the Deadpool
movie and this doesn't come as that big
of a surprise as 6 Underground's recent
with Michael Bay in Netflix is 6
underground which was also written by
the Deadpool riders Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick so basically the dead
about him directing the next step pull
film not to mention that before the
Transformers movies Michael Bay used to
be pretty tight with Disney so it is
possible but so busy that the old x-men
Fox universe
I personally think it's a genius idea I
think it's really early what he would
have to say as he's going around killing
everybody breaking the fourth wall but
let me know what you all would think
about this and the comments down below
would you like to see this happen
yeah all three let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and I don't
forget to warm up the video and plot it
you have to aren't on everything
relating to the MCU oh yeah thank you
warm on Twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
wolf boy wow that is something man that
is an interesting piece of news you're
the comic book movie predictor I've been
saying that like if they really want to
do this transition properly especially
with bridging the gaps and completely
eliminating confusions you should use
Deadpool as your character to do it
because he can talk to the audience do
the fourth wall breaking and he could do
all the things to help clear up anything
that might be confusing but also
transitioning some of the Fox characters
so they've now inherited over to here
and especially because of the fact that
they're keeping Ryan Reynolds's Deadpool
he would just be the perfect vessel for
this entire transition to start a brand
new x-men to have an established
Fantastic Four to do all that and you
blade I know most of us especially the
ones who follow the movie news and
whatever aren't confused by it but I
still meet some people even in LA you
know the capital of the Hollywood
industry I still meet some people who
are average moviegoers who still get
confused on the spider-man stuff so this
would be a great way to really solidify
at all and I just I love this idea you
could also bring back people who played
former Charles Xavier magneto you know
like Michael Fassbender for actors
Patrick Stewart well the only two actors
for each of those roles you said any
Lana Kelly and Michael Fair actors two
characters per Walters for
wrong the only two actor antic no ji I
think you said it Terry I would like a
review Christian anyway I do think that
this is like the perfect idea I would
love it
in terms of Michael Bay directing John
what are your thoughts I'll let you
speak I don't know I mean Michael Bates
me is a filmmaker who if you give him a
good script he'll probably make a decent
movie out of that script I would be very
curious to see how he plays with team
Marvel team Disney team we have a lot of
control and you're used to having a lot
of control and blah blah blah but it
also would just be an exciting ly
eccentric prospect to me especially with
a movie is wild and bonkers as Deadpool
kills any type of universe movie would
and ought to be it would get me
interested in a Michael Bay joint in a
different way like I would have another
reason to be interested Beyond morbid
curiosity as to whether he appeals more
to my sensibility but this seems like a
wonderful idea all the way around
because you can not only add to your
continuity correcting but you can also
play into some of the aspects of how
cinema especially superhero cinema has
become incredibly self-aware
self-conscious and beholden to fan
voices and true outside input and you
can literally break the fourth wall and
confront some of those things that are
about the construction and you might not
clear up everybody's confusion I think
this could be a really fun prospect all
the way around that could do a lot of
good and can also get a Greatest Hits
medley of moments that could do some
justice to and send off certain
characters you get your Wolverine
appearance and one more time from Hugh
Jackman you could literally touch on any
of the previous Fox outside Marvel
properties in a fun way that could let
them you know be put to rest for now
well it's like all those previous
properties none of them ended on a high
note you know what I mean it's like
Wolverine did in Logan but the x-men
franchise do not Fantastic Four
certainly didn't eric vanna's Hulk yeah
I mean even maybe Wesley Snipes might be
game no one's really thought about this
but what's those times might be game to
like have a little bit of a cameo as
well considering the disaster blade
Trinity was yeah I mean Michael Bay
directing it
I thought that david leitch was still
attached to do this and i was I was on
board for that because I'm one of the
few people that actually prefers
deadpool 2 over deadpool 1 i love them
both but i think i just my preference is
deadpool - i feel like he'll be fine
i feel like in a weird way they that
mashup works I haven't seen six
underground but from what I've heard
that it is a solid Michael Bay film that
capitalizes on Ryan Reynolds humor I
guess the weird construct of it to me is
Michael Bay can be a control freak
supposedly right I don't know the guy my
area is Brian Reynolds he has control
over the way Deadpool generally operates
and the storytelling
hence the situation that occurred with
Tim Miller from Deadpool one a devil -
maybe they just see eye to eye on things
and it could be something that's a
beautiful medley he might be able to
speak Bay yeah that is true and it makes
me wonder because I feel like one of two
things are the case here where I think
you know Tim Miller and David Leitch
they're not bigger than the presence of
Deadpool whereas like Michael Bay is
such a huge presence of his own that
it's almost like a team-up
in and of itself to have him direct that
movie which I think could either be a
little too much on the worst case
scenario or it could be like some kind
of weird turbo charge in the best case
in Ryan it'd be interesting to see him
pick up part three because it's like
other people have picked up his
franchises he's taken his own - part
five yeah it would be fascinating to see
like how he would just completely do is
I mean for sure would be very long and
bonkers but would he were my 7 into the
title it might be what's necessary
though alright guys well what do you
think of this Deadpool 3 idea that Ryan
Reynolds pitched leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to cost wonder if
you haven't done so already you can
subscribe at the real rejects click that
notification about like a notify
whenever we got a video up and thank you
gpk for sponsoring this video go check
them out
you